The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Today
we're going to talk--
or it's the first
technical discussion
of the actual solar
cell device itself.
We talked last
class about the sun
and about the nature
of the solar resource.
Today we're going to be talking
about the interaction of light
with matter.
In particular, we're
focusing on light absorption.
This lecture could alternatively
be called "Light Not Getting
Absorbed" or "Optical Losses."
Both are important, and both
are related, as we'll see.
So this is part of the
fundamentals of the course.
Just to situate
ourselves, we're here
right now in the fundamentals,
the first third of course.
Then we'll talk about
the technologies
and the cross-cutting themes.
And what we're
going to talk about
is extremely important
because it allows us
to understand the technologies.
Once we begin discussing them
and we discuss cost trade
offs of implementing
this particular technique
for the way for it
to absorb more light,
we can appreciate how
much we can quantify
the impact of that
technology development,
and we could also later
on ascribe a cost to it,
to determine the total
cost benefit analysis.
So conversion
efficiency is really
what dictates the performance
of the device, the solar cell
device.
It's how the solar cell device
converts sunlight, the input
energy, to some usable
output energy, which
is in the form of electricity,
typically, from a solar panel.
so the electricity
coming out of these
leads, for instance, right here.
And that conversion efficiency,
that simple equation,
for most solar cells, can
break down into the following.
You have inputs.
Sorry for the small font here.
This reads solar spectrum.
That's your input.
Your output, which is
the charge collection,
it's a collective charge
coming out of your device,
and a bunch of steps in between.
So from the solar spectrum,
we have to absorb that light,
then we have to excite
charge within the material.
Then that charge has to move
around inside the material
to get to the metallic
context in the front side.
Charge separation has to occur
for there to be a voltage.
And finally, the charge
collection process.
And so the total
efficiency of this device
is the product of each of
these individual processes.
And so if you're making
a solar cell device,
and I know about a third of you
are based on your background
surveys, this diagram right
here will ring true to you.
It's Liebig's Law
of the Minimum.
What this is
representing is a barrel
that has water being
dripped into it.
And the water will flow out
of whatever piece of wood
is the shortest.
And in the case of
a solar cell device,
you can ascribe a
certain name to each
of these pieces of wood.
We'll learn what each
of those are with time.
But one of the big
ones is optical losses.
And the optical losses
tend to be rather severe
on some of our lab scale cells.
So one of the easiest ways
of boosting efficiency
is simply to take care
of your optical losses
and to minimize the amount of
light reflected or not absorbed
into maximizing amount of
life that's actually absorbed.
And so to do that,
there are a number
of standard techniques and some
cutting edge research areas.
And I'll attempt to give
you a broad overview
and survey of both,
assuming, of course,
you've done your
background reading.
So the learning
objectives, the first
is to be able to
calculate the reflectance
in non-absorption optical
losses of a solar cell.
So this is essentially all
the light that's not absorbed.
We want to be able
to calculate that.
The second is to describe
the physical underpinnings
and the implementations of four
to five-- there are five here.
I added one at the end.
Four to five advanced methods
of reducing optical losses.
So there are
technologies, techniques
that we've used that we've
developed over time that we can
use to minimize
the optical losses,
to minimize the amount of
light reflected or not absorbed
inside of a solar cell device.
So to think of this
pictorially, we
can come up with the
following diagram, where
we have some incident energy,
in this case incident light.
Here's our medium.
Here's the amount of
light that gets absorbed.
Here's the amount of light
that gets transmitted right
through that does not get
absorbed within the material
upon passing through it.
And there's a certain
amount of light
that just gets reflected off
the front of your solar cell
device.
We want to, obviously,
maximize this part right here.
So to begin, we
give a quick review
of light, the nature of light.
This is going back to the
particle wave duality of light.
It will be useful alternatively
to think about light
as a particle, quant of
light, or to think about light
as a wave, depending on what
light management technique
we're going to be describing.
And in particular, I'd
like to just highlight
these equations over here.
The notion that one can define
the energy of a photon coming
in, and that photon has
a certain wavelength,
a certain frequency, a
certain wave length associated
with it-- frequency and
wavelength-- related,
of course, by the
speed of light,
Planck's constant, and so forth.
So just to situate ourselves
with broad numbers,
so when we dive in and talk
about spatial dimensions
in relation to the
wavelength of the light,
we're in a situation
where we can actually
have a horse sense, a
common sense, about it.
The visible photon
wavelengths are usually
in the hundreds of nanometers.
And the solar spectrum
peaks somewhere around 550,
just good numbers
to have in mind.
So this was that solar spectrum,
the integrated solar radiance
versus wavelength.
And the second point
that is equally valid,
we can describe the wavelengths
of the incoming light,
wavelengths of the
incoming light lambda,
or we can describe the energies
of the incoming light, this E
sub ph, the energy
of the photons.
So just to situate
ourselves again,
the visible photon energies
are typically in a range of 0.6
to 6 eV, electron volts,
again, with the peak
of the solar spectrum at
550 nanometers, somewhere
around 2.3 eV.
Good.
So a simple thing to keep in
mind, for those high energy
particle physicists
in the room, that when
we're talking about
visible light,
we're interacting with a very
specific type of electron
inside of our system.
It's the valence electrons.
These are the electrons that
are typically most loosely bound
inside of a system
or I would say
in the outer shells of the
atoms within the material.
You're typically not interacting
with core shell electrons
with visible light.
For that, you need x-rays.
So this is just something
to keep in mind.
When we start looking at
the wavelength dependence
of absorption inside
of a material,
you can have, for example, in
the visible range, a decreasing
depth of penetration of the
light with increasing energy,
whereas with x-rays,
it's the exact opposite.
It's because you're dealing with
different types of electrons
and the material.
So just to situate
ourselves, I know
we have a fair number physicists
and chemists in the room.
That's a message
geared toward them.
Let's describe how light
interacts with matter.
And first off, come up
with a few variables.
Define a few units that
will make it easier
for us to understand how light
is interacting with matter.
And so here what
I've done for you
is placed the equation that
describes the complex index
of refraction of a material.
What this means,
effectively, you
can think about this refractive
index of the material
as being comprised of
two different components.
For now, it's going
to be fairly cerebral,
but I'm going to
reduce it to practicing
in a couple of slides.
The real component of
the refractive index--
and the refractive index is
material-specific property.
So if I have, for
example, silicon
or if I have silicon
nitride or if I
have a particular
type of glass, it'll
refractive index.
It's comprised of a
real component which
indicates the phase velocity
inside of the material
and an imaginary
component, which
can be thought of as an
extinction coefficient.
And it is related
to the attenuation
of the light intensity as it
travels through that material.
The measurements for those who
have already taken measurements
before on a spectroscopic
ellipsometer, this
is how you measure that
parameter up there.
We don't have to dive
too deeply into that
for the purposes of the class.
It's just for background.
Why these values are
important-- these values
here describe the interaction
of light inside of a medium,
inside of a material.
And we use that
information to calculate
engineering relevant parameters
such as reflectance of light
off of a surface.
So if we want to calculate what
is the reflectance of light off
of the silicon right
here, I can calculate it
by knowing these
properties right here,
by knowing the real and
imaginary components
of the refractive index
of silicon, in this case.
And the reason
that's important is
because we want to minimize
reflection off of surfaces.
So I've come up with
the first equation
right here which is describing
the reflectance from air
to a solid, in this
case, from air where
the refractive index
is 1 to a solid,
namely, say for example,
silicon right here
or glass, which has a finite
refractive index typically
greater than 1.
And so I have an equation here
that describes the reflectance.
Let me dive a little
deeper into it
and try to understand
what exactly
that equation is telling me.
So from the folks who have
studied mechanics, many of you
are mechanical
engineers in the room,
you may recall studying a
problem wherein you have
two springs that are connected.
They have different
spring constants,
different stiffnesses,
shall we say.
And you excite a wave over here.
It travels down.
And when it reaches the
interface between the two,
part of the wave
is reflected back
and part continues through.
The speed of the
wave is changing
as it goes from one
spring to the other,
because the stiffness is
changing of the springs.
And the amount reflected can
be described by this equation
right here, which looks
awfully like the equation
right above it, which is
describing the amount of light
reflected off of an interface.
And in reality, those ends have
a very similar meaning, the n
and the z.
The n, in the case
of light, which
is the real components
of the refractive index.
Mind you, this
parameter right here,
this indicates phase
velocity in material.
It could also be
thought of very loosely
as the ability of an
electromagnetic wave coming
into material to slosh
those electrons around.
Not exactly a
stiffness coefficient,
but it bears some
rough resemblance.
So this is a method for
you to gain a foothold
in this new area
of understanding
the refractive
index of a material
based on something you've
already seen before.
So I would advise
taking this analogy
as far as it will go
until it breaks down.
Push it as far as it goes
And you'll see at some
point it actually does,
but it's a useful
place to start.
So I'm going to ask you
a couple of questions.
This might be rather
new for a lot of folks.
But the purpose of
asking these questions
is to get you thinking.
And eventually we'll get
to a point of heightened
understanding as a result.
Tinted windows.
So if you have a
tinted window, what
is typically happening
at that tinted window?
Why can't you see inside?
What would you
imagine is going on?
So let me go back to
this reflectance equation
right here, this one.
How would you modify
a reflectance off
of a window, let's say?
And let's drop the k's for now.
Let's leave those aside and
just focus on this parameter
right here, n minus
1 quantity squared
n plus 1 quantity squared.
What would increase the
reflectance off of that window,
if I have a larger
n or a smaller n?
If I have a bigger n, I
would get bigger reflectance.
Is that right?
r goes up?
Well, you'd have to
plot it out, I guess.
So if I change the refractive
index of the material
that I am working with, I can
change the reflectivity off
of that interface,
off of that surface.
So if I add a
coating, for instance,
to a window that increases
the reflectivity,
then the amount of light that is
able to escape from the inside
to my eyes decreases.
Now, with normal
incident light, there
is a beautiful
symmetry involved.
That is, the amount
reflected off of one side
is equal to the amount of light
reflected off the other side.
So just the same way that
I'm losing the ability
to see inside, the
folks inside are also
losing the ability to see out.
But they can still see out.
Why is that?
Why is it that with
the same reflectivity
they're able to see
outside and I'm not
able to see in through that
tinted window, through that
car, for example, that's driving
by with the tinted glass?
Why can't I see insight but they
can see out, what's going on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI:
Yeah, I hear somebody.
AUDIENCE: The light
on the outside
is much stronger in terms of
an absolute amount of light
being reflected.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yep, exactly.
So yes, the reflectivity
as a percentage
is the same for both parties.
But the amount of
light, the magnitude
of the light from the
outside, is much, much greater
than it is on the inside.
Can anybody give me
just a gut sense.
If I'm outside on a sunny
day, how much brighter
is it outside versus
inside right here?
Factor of?
AUDIENCE: 100, maybe?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Maybe a factor
of 10, somewhere in that range.
And so when you walk
outside on a sunny day,
you'll notice your eyes
adjusting a little bit.
It'll take a minute.
And when we walk back inside,
it will take a minute here
for your eyes to adjust as well.
That's because of the
difference in intensities.
So if you imagine being
outside of that car
and having 10 times the amount
of light being reflected,
that small amount of light
that is actually transmitting
through the window from the
car to the outside world
will be washed out by the
amount of reflected light.
Whereas if you're
inside the car,
there's a lot of light
coming through that window,
even though a lot of
it gets reflected,
there's still a sizable
amount coming through.
And the amount of
light that gets
reflected off that window
of the internal light
is small in relation to
the outside light that
is being transmitted
through that window.
So it's important to think
about these processes,
both in terms of their
reflectance as a percentage
but also the magnitudes
of the light involved.
What if that glass pane
was flipped around?
Would it change anything?
If I took that glass and just
flipped it, would it change it?
What about the
symmetry argument,
that the amount of light is
reflected, the r reflectance,
is the same from both sides?
AUDIENCE: Is it not
the case that there's
a coating on the outside?
So if the change
in refracted index
is an abrupt change
from the outside looking
at this coating.
Because on the
inside, you're going
through some median glass,
which is more index matched
than the outside.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
Yeah, so I would
advise you to actually walk
through that calculation.
And what you'll find is it
winds up being the same.
And it's because you have
to take all reflectances off
of all these interfaces
into account.
There are, in fact, three
interfaces-- the air,
the glass; the glass, the
anti-reflection coding;
and the anti-reflection
coding, the outside.
This, of course, without getting
into quarter wave effects,
which we'll get into
a minute, there's
some higher order effects that
deal with phase change, which
we haven't discussed right now.
We're just assuming
that all of these layers
are well above the wavelength of
the light in terms of thickness
and that these equations, these
linear equations, are valid.
Very good.
So this is just
to get us situated
with this new concept
of reflectance--
and again, very
powerful equation.
Keep in mind that this
is a very specific form
of the reflectance from
an air into a solid.
If you're going from
a solid into a solid,
you'll add your n1
and your n2, depending
on what material going into and
what material are coming from.
So we're happy to walk through
that perhaps during recitation.
OK, so what we're
going to do now
is we've talked about
reflectance off of surfaces.
What I'd like to do is talk
about a light absorption
inside of a material.
So let's imagine that through
the techniques that we're
going to be discussing
later on in lecture,
we manage to minimize
the amount of reflectance
off the front surface.
And now the light that's
incident on the material
is actually going to go
inside and get absorbed
by the material inside.
We need to be able to understand
how light gets absorbed inside
of matter.
And for that, we apply a very
simple formulation inside
of this class, which is called
Beer-Lambert's Law, which
is a very simple
yet very powerful
formulation that describes not
only the interaction of light
with the solar cell
material but also
light through the
atmosphere, light the water,
many other forms of
optical absorption.
And for that, I'd like to
call Joe up for a quick demo
that he put together that will
allow us to actually plot out
Beer-Lambert's Law.
And I'd like to start
with what I would think
of as a simple hypothesis.
What we're going to
be doing, and Joe
will explain this a minute,
what we're going to be doing
is taking many
sheets of material.
This is just some
polyethylene material,
a little bit discolored.
And we're going to shine a laser
down on to this photodiode.
The photodiode current
will be measured
by this little current
meter right here.
And we'll be inserting these
panes of plastic in the middle.
And as we increase the
thickness of the plastic,
applying good
pressure in between
to minimize the reflectance,
the air gap, for instance--
as we increase the thickness
of the polyethylene,
we will plot the total
transmitted light
as measured by that photodiode.
And so I'm going to come up
with a hypothesis of what's
going to happen.
I'm going to say
that if we double
the thickness of
the polyethylene
that we're going to halve the
amount of light going through.
And if we triple, we're going
to reduce it by a third.
And if we quadruple, we're
going to reduce it by a fourth.
And let's see if the
hypothesis is correct.
It's not.
But we're going to test it.
And it's a logical
thing you might assume.
And then we'll walk
through a derivation that
will correct our missed logic.
So go ahead, Joe.
Take it away.
JOE: Sure, so if you guys want
to play along, that's fine too.
I know there's lines in
the side of your notes.
You can make little graph
paper, and it comes out
looking really nice.
So basically what we have is a
laser pointed and a photodiode.
And the current out
of this photodiode
is directly proportional to the
light hitting that photodiode.
And it has a quant
efficiency, which
we're going to learn what
that is in a few lectures,
of about 60%.
So of the photons
hitting it, you'll
get a certain number
of electrons out,
and that ratio's 60%.
And so first of all,
we're going to see
what it's like, what
the power of our-- yeah.
So right now we're getting
about 1.32 milliamps.
So Tonio's going to plot that.
Then as we keep increasing and
put one layer of polyethylene,
that drops to 0.75.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
So before we go
onto the next one,
what do people
predict the next dot is going
to drop the total intensity to?
Is it going to be kind of
a linear line like that?
You'd expect it, right,
because you're doubling it.
So you'd expect the intensity
to drop by another factor of 2.
Why not?
Where am I getting
a mistake here?
Somebody says exponential.
There's kind of this sense
that it should be exponential.
What don't we add some
more filter in front,
and we'll see what exactly
this comes out to be.
JOE: This is with two.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Two.
JOE: Now we get 0.43.
TONIO BUONASSISI: 0.43.
OK.
All right.
Why don't we do one more just
to see what sort of trend
we're getting.
Still 0.26.
JOE: 0.26.
TONIO BUONASSISI: 0.26.
Ah, wow.
OK, so it didn't go
in a straight line.
It's actually starting
to curve down.
Cool.
OK.
JOE: And we keep going, 0.16.
TONIO BUONASSISI: 0.16
JOE: 0.10
TONIO BUONASSISI: 0.10.
OK.
Look at that.
What sort of curve is it?
Exponential.
It looks like one at least.
And we can test whether
or not the hypothesis
is correct by an
exponential fit, which
happens to match pretty well.
So--
JOE: Now one other
quick thing you notice
is that if you look at the fit,
the first point's a little bit
higher than that fit.
Anyone have an idea of why
that might be the case?
What are we ignoring
in this experiment?
AUDIENCE: The reflection
is [INAUDIBLE].
JOE: The reflections, yeah.
So in the first one,
you reflect light,
and certain amount
gets transmitted
through that front
surface than absorbs.
And so right now we're ignoring
this is 1 minus r component.
But it's so small
that it really doesn't
matter for this experiment.
These things don't
reflect a lot of light.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Cool.
Well, why don't we
give a quick rondo.
[APPLAUSE]
Well done.
Can I grab one of those?
JOE: Absolutely.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
This is going to be
important for the
immersion scattering demo.
JOE: Oh, sure.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yep.
Cool.
OK, so we notice that we have
some exponential character
to be decay of the intensity
of the transmitted light
through a medium.
And the amount that's absorbed
is following another trend,
which is just 1 minus that.
So it's the amount
of light that's
absorbed is following a curve
looks something like that.
OK, so let's look through the
formalism of Beer-Lambert Law
and try to understand
why it is that we come up
with that exponential
function right here.
So if we assume that light
is coming in a medium
and light is decaying in
some function to that medium
and a certain amount of
light is transmitted,
we know, of course, from
our little experiment
that it follows some
exponential function.
But how do we justify
that to ourselves?
Well, first off, we're
going to ignore reflections
off the front surface.
We just talked about them.
We can calculate them.
Let's leave that aside for
now as a parallel calculation.
We're just concerning
ourselves with what's
happening inside of the medium.
So if we assume that
the change of intensity
within that medium in each
little delta thickness
is going to be affected by some
sort of scattering intensity
within the medium--
and this sigma here
can refer to a
variety of processes.
That can refer to
absorption events
that result in the
generation of free charge.
They can refer to
absorption events that
just heat the material up
and generate phonons, so
lattice vibrations.
There are a number of processes
embedded in the sigma,
and that's why this formalism
is so powerful, because it
doesn't care really what the
physical nature of that sigma
is.
It just matters that there is
an absorption per unit distance
thickness traveled inside
of the material that
is constant throughout
the entire material.
So the sigma here is independent
of thickness throughout.
And then as you integrate
through, you wind up
with that beautiful exponential
function at the end,
the sigma l times n.
We collapse the n and the
sigma here into an alpha.
That alpha is an
absorption coefficient.
The l is the total length or the
total thickness of this medium
right here.
So if we increase
the total thickness,
we're going to decrease
the total amount of light
coming through via that
exponential function.
The alpha, on the other hand,
is not a geometric parameter.
It's an intrinsic
material parameter.
To put that in terms of
mechanical engineering,
for many of the mechanical
engineers in the room,
you recall from solid
mechanics, 2001,
that you have geometric
parameters that determine, say
for example, structural
response and intrinsic material
parameters like
Young's modulus that
determine the structural
response of a system.
And likewise in
here, in the optical,
shall we say, response, we
have a fundamental intrinsic
material parameter, r alpha,
the absorption coefficient,
and the geometric parameter,
rl, which is the thickness.
And the beauty of
this formalism right
here is that we can
measure, experimentally
just like we did right there,
our alphas for materials.
And so from an
engineering point of view,
we don't really--
to first order,
it doesn't really matter
what sort of scattering
or absorption process
is happening inside
of a material for us
to calculate the amount
of transmitted light.
We just need to know the alpha.
We need to know the optical
absorption coefficient.
This alpha will vary as a
function of wavelength inside
of a material
because, obviously,
the physical absorption
mechanisms are varying
as a function of wavelength.
The resonances with
different electronic states
within the material,
that light, depends
on the energy of the light,
depends on the frequency.
So there's a
wavelength dependence.
Yeah, and that general
equation is the same one that
drives the reduction
of light intensity
as it travels through
the atmosphere.
So if we increase the
atmospheric path length,
we'll be reducing the amount
of light that actually reaches
the surface of the earth.
That's at air mass
two or air mass three,
there's less solar
flux coming down
than at air mass one
or air mass zero.
The alpha, obviously,
is going to be
very different
for our atmosphere
than it was for these
little polyethylene sheets.
Because the nature of the
scattering and absorption
processes are very
different for the atmosphere
than it is for here, the density
of the material and so forth.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What was n?
TONIO BUONASSISI: So the n,
there's a certain scattering
intensity, and then there's
a certain number density,
for example, of the material.
So this alpha here is, I
would say, density neutral.
What we've done is we have
the alpha encapsulating
the physical parameters
of the material
and the absorption processes
all in one variable,
very nicely and succinctly.
And the only geometric
parameter that is of essence
is really our l.
AUDIENCE: It's called an
absorption coefficient,
but is it more of an
extension coefficient, really?
Because it's kind of confusing
that it includes scattering.
TONIO BUONASSISI: The extension
coefficient, absorption
coefficient, yes,
in solar research,
when we talk about an
absorption coefficient
inside of a material.
Oftentimes we're operating in
a wavelength regime of light
wherein free charge is excited.
But we can also keep increasing
that the wavelength of light,
say, out to 10 microns, very
long wavelength light, very
low energy light.
And that can excite
free carriers
within the material--
carriers that
are already excited, essentially
excited them further,
without generating
any new free carriers
inside of our material.
So we won't necessarily
be generating
more current by
shedding light on it
but will be absorbing light,
nevertheless, in our material.
So it's important
to keep, let's say,
the underlying
physical processes that
are occurring distinct.
Later on we'll get to that.
For now, it's important
just to, I would say,
recognize that we have
an exponential decay
of the intensity of the light
as it goes through the medium.
And then over the
next few classes,
we're going to get to exactly
what physical processes are
going on.
But I'm glad people are
asking those questions.
OK, so again,
alpha is a function
of the wavelength of light and
the property of the medium.
And let me just
flash up some curves
of alpha versus wavelength
so people have some exposure
to those numbers.
Again, we're talking about
an energy range quite broad
here, from about
6.2 eV to 0.62 eV.
The visible
wavelengths range would
be somewhere in
this regime right
here, so a very limited band.
And the infrared out here,
ultraviolet over here,
and we can see for a variety
of different types of materials
what the absorption
coefficient is.
So here we have germanium.
The red would be crystalline
silicon, gallium arsenide,
indium phosphide, and
amorphous silicon.
So let's do a little
quick calculation
just to get us a little limber.
We're starting to get
into the semester,
so the energy level
starts going down.
What we're going to do is
we're going to pick a value,
say 550 nanometers.
Why did I pick 550 again?
It's near the peak of the
solar spectrum, right?
It matters.
And we're going to look at
two different materials.
We're going to look at
silicon, and we're going
to look at gallium arsenide.
And we're going to
calculate the thickness
necessary to absorb 90%
of the incoming light
at 550 nanometers.
What I want you to do is
turn to your neighbor,
and once again
with your neighbor,
calculate what
thickness of material,
what thickness of gallium
arsenide, the yellow curve,
and what thickness of
silicon, the red curve,
is necessary to absorb
90% of the incoming light
at 550 nanometers.
Why don't you go for it?
I'll give you, say,
a couple minutes.
To make sure people are
setting this up right,
i divided by i0 to absorb
90% of the light, that
would be 0.1, 1 minus 0.9.
OK, so as you're finalizing
your calculations,
I just wanted to make
sure set this up right.
Again, if we're absorbing 90%
of the light, it means only 10%
of the light is going
out the other side.
That means their i is
going to be 1/10 of i0
or i divided by i0 is 0.1.
And then we would take
the log of both sides,
typically, and solve for
our l based on the alphas
that we have here.
Again, units of alpha would
be in inverse centimeters.
And so the l's
that you obtained,
let's go for gallium
arsenide first.
Did anybody manage
to walk all the way
through that calculation?
AUDIENCE: 20 micrometers.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
20 micrometers.
For our gallium arsenide
or for our silicon?
AUDIENCE: Gallium arsenide.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
Gallium arsenide.
Did anybody get any other
numbers for gallium arsenide.
AUDIENCE: 0.4.
TONIO BUONASSISI: 0.4 microns.
Yeah.
That's sounding more
in the ballpark.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: 23.
TONIO BUONASSISI: 23 as well.
So I'm getting-- I would have
guessed that the number would
rather small for
gallium arsenide, so
something in the range of,
say, a micron, in that order.
Why don't we give folks
enough time to walk through--
I know I rushed you on
the calculations here.
We have material to get through.
And I wanted to see you
perform under pressure.
But how about the silicon?
Is it larger or smaller?
Let's just for order
of magnitude first
and the general
trend and then try
to pick up the precise number.
For silicon,
crystalline silicon that
is, with an optical
absorption coefficient
and order of magnitude
less than gallium arsenide,
is the thickness needed to
absorb the same amount of light
going to be greater or smaller?
AUDIENCE: Greater.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Greater.
By an--
AUDIENCE: Order of magnitude.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Order
of magnitude, brilliant.
OK.
So whatever number you
got for your gallium,
arsenide you could
translate it fairly easily.
All right, so that was at 550.
And there's a lot of solar
radiation right around 550,
so the numbers that I
have on the top my head
work somewhere out to be
on the order of a micron,
a little less for
gallium arsenide,
somewhere in the order of
10 microns or so for silicon
out here.
But now if we go
out to 800, there's
still a lot of solar
flux out there.
If you recall the solar
spectrum, the folks who
have been doing their homework,
there's still a lot of flux
out around 800.
As a matter of fact, it
continues going all the way out
to here, although decaying
intensity a la black body.
And at 800 nanometers
wavelength light,
the optical
absorption coefficient
is dropped by about
an order of magnitude
relative to the peak
of the solar spectrum.
And that's why most of
these solar cells that you
see of crystalline silicon are
on the order of 100 microns,
typically a little thicker for
some technological reasons,
which we'll get to, make
it difficult to handle
very, very thin stuff.
But if you just assume one
pass through the material,
you'd need about that thickness
to absorb a lot of the light.
And I'll pass around
some of these materials
right here just so you can get
a sense of how thick they are.
Here we go.
Actually, here's
what I'm going to do.
I'm going to take
out the big pieces
and leave the small ones in
here that are already broken.
And you can actually
pick them up if you like.
Just be aware that these
little pieces of silicon
are-- silicon's
brittle material.
It's like glass.
So if you have a little
shard of silicon,
it can poke you just like
a charge of glass can.
So treat it with the
same amount of respect
that you would a very,
very thin piece of glass.
But you can see here
that if you look
at the thickness
of these materials
inside of that little bin, these
are small shards of silicon
solar cell wafers.
Their thicknesses in the
order of 100 microns, those
are particularly thin.
You have other
solar cells that are
170 microns is typical
thickness for silicon.
And for gallium
arsenide, you can
deposit thin films
that are on the order
of a micron thick or less.
You can go down to a
few hundreds nanometers
and still make-- actually
the record efficiency
of gallium arsenide solar
cell is a few hundred
nanometers thick.
And our calculations
right here assumed
one pass through the material.
That's all we gave the light.
We only gave one chance
to go through the material
and get absorbed.
What could you envision would
increase the total amount
of light absorbed?
What could you do to
your solar cell device
to increase the total amount
of light absorbed inside of it?
AUDIENCE: Put anti-relfective
coating on it.
TONIO BUONASSISI: You could put
anti-reflective coating on it.
Let's do something
much more simple.
AUDIENCE: Put reflective
coating on the back.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Reflecting
coating on the back,
absolutely.
Yeah.
So if the light goes through
the solar cell and doesn't get
absorbed, that 10% of the
light that didn't make it,
that's going to
get reflected back.
It's going to get another
chance to go through.
So if you absorb 90% of the
light on the first pass,
you'll absorb 99% of the
light on two bounces, right?
Or in one bounce,
rather, and two trips,
two optical path links
through the material.
And so the term
optical path length
is a very important term
here, because the optical path
length does not have to be
the thickness of the material.
Ideally, the optical path
length through the material
is much, much thicker than
the actual material itself.
And over the next
few slides, we're
going to learn how
we engineer that.
So methods to improve optical
absorption- generally,
these are called light trapping.
Not all of these entail
trapping the light.
Actually, most of them do.
We also call them
light management
as a more general
term that includes
reflection and absorption
inside of the material.
So the very simplest thing we
can do on the front surface--
so what we're
going to do is take
this step by step, as light
goes into the solar cell
from the front side, we're
going to take step by step,
what can we do to improve
the amount of light that
is absorbed?
The first thing that we can do
is texturize our front surface.
If we don't have texture
on our front surface,
if it's absolutely
flat, what we call
specular surface-- specular
coming from the root mirror.
In Latin languages, for example,
Italian specchio is mirror.
So a flat silicon substrate,
a specular surface,
would reflect some
finite amount of light.
And we can calculate
that now because we
know that it relates
to the real component
of the refractive
index of the material.
Now if we texturize
our surface--
this is representing kind of
a pyramid type texturization.
If the light comes in
and some fraction doesn't
go into the material--
there's some component
of that ray that's going
into the material over here,
but we're ignoring
it in this drawing.
We're just focusing
on the lights,
the rays that get reflected.
That beam that
gets reflected off,
instead of just going
back out toward the sun,
it's now going toward
the material again.
So it has a second chance
of getting absorbed.
So you just went--
for example, let's say
if you have a 10%
reflectivity on the surface,
you went from a 10%
reflectivity over here
to a 1% reflectivity over here.
Because now you have the total
amount of light that gets
reflected is 1 minus 0.9 squared
as opposed to 1 minus 0.9
to the 1.
In this case right here, the
amount of light that gets
reflected, assuming
its 10% reflective,
would be 1 minus
0.9, so 10% of light.
And over here, the
amount of light that gets
reflected would be 1 minus
0.9 quantity squared, so 1%
instead of 10%.
So texturization
increases the probability
that light will
enter the device.
And what it also does-- this
is a secondary benefit--
is it increases the path length,
the effective path length,
of the incoming light.
And the way to understand
that particular phenomena
is called Snell's Law.
Well, even in the absence
of Snell's Law-- no,
let's go there.
Let's go there.
So we have a texturized
front surface.
What's happening?
Well, as the material goes
from one medium to another,
the refractive index changes.
We discussed this right at
the beginning of lecture.
So the way in which the
electromagnetic wave oscillates
the electrons
instead of the system
is changing from one
medium to another,
let's say from air into the
solar cell device from air
into our silicon, for
example, right here.
Now, we can ascribe the
refractive indices to air
and to our silicon like so.
And the light path
will obey what
is called Snell's Law,
which is the product
of the refractive index and
sine of that angle, the angle
relative to the surface normal.
So a simple way to
think about this
is when the light goes from a
low index of refraction medium
to a high index of refraction
medium, light bends
toward or away from the normal?
So if I'm going from
air into silicon,
light would bend toward
the normal, right?
So here my theta 1 is going
to be greater than theta 2.
My light has bent toward the
normal, if this is my silicon
and this white stuff
over here is my air.
So light came in.
It encountered the surface.
The theta 1 was defined
as the angle of the light
relative to the surface normal.
That was my theta 1.
My theta 2 is going to
be given as the ratio
of the refractive indices.
And because the refractive
index of silicon
is going to be greater
than that of air,
light would bend
toward the normal.
And so what I have on a
macroscopic view over here,
if this is my surface
texture, light was coming in,
it's now bent.
And so the effective
optical path length
is now larger than the
thickness of my device.
It's kind of cool.
So there are two benefits to
texturizing your front surface.
One is you have an additional
pass, additional bounce,
an additional encounter
with the material.
So that reflected light gets
another chance to go in.
And the second
benefit is that you're
able to increase
the optical path
length by the delta in
refractive indices and the fact
that the path of the
light will be Snell's Law.
Now another really interesting
aside of Snell's Law
is that if light is trying to
go from a high index medium
to a low index medium,
and if it's coming in
at a very oblique
angle like this,
if you run through
Snell's Law, you
don't get an angle coming out.
It actually falls
along the surface
or actually bounces back in most
often, depending on the angle.
And you have what is called
total internal reflection,
which is this case
right over here.
That little bounce,
that friendly bounce,
of the light that went in
bounced off the back side
and then was reflected back in.
That's a total internal
reflection event.
And that happens
in solar modules.
Right here, when light
comes in, bounces off
of the white back
skin right here,
and then gets scattered
off at an angle,
it can have a total
internal reflection off
of the front surface
glass and have
a second chance of getting back
into the solar cells inside.
So that's one of the reasons
why you see this white spacing,
the white colored material,
in between the cells,
is that the light gets
reflected off of there.
It doesn't make it very
aesthetically pleasing.
You might want it
to look all black.
And if you do want it to
look all black, what would
you do instead?
Instead of changing the back
skin, what other component
might you change?
AUDIENCE: The front.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
The front, right?
You might change the nature
of the anti-reflection coating
on the glass.
We'll get anti-reflection
coatings in a minute.
So even if the
panel looks black,
there are some really
aesthetically pleasing
solar panels out there
that look completely black.
They may still have
white back skin,
but the glass is just very
good at absorbing that light
and preventing it from escaping.
OK, so to engineer front and
back surface reflectances,
you really have to
carefully select
your refractive indices
and your materials
if you put on either side.
And it's very important--
extremely important.
To make a long story short, the
record efficiency solar cell
that was announced this past
year in gallium arsenide
was achieved because of
good light management.
And we'll explain how that came
about perhaps towards lectures,
maybe lectures eight or nine.
So I'm going to play a
little game with you, which
is to look at a swimming pool.
This is a pool
filled with water,
which is refractive index 1.3.
Air is 1.
And so that's the normal
view, what we have.
Light bends toward
the normal, right?
And so you're able to
look down inside the pool
that stuff that is not
in your line of sight,
not in your direct
line of sight.
That's because when you
look down, the ray of light
is traveling like
this and it bends
toward the normal and
likewise symmetric.
So you're seeing
material down there.
What change of
property would give you
these two images over here.
Let me give you a hint.
In one of those two images,
the refractive index
of the medium inside
the pool is not 1.3.
It's 0.9.
And in another one of these
two, the refractive index
of the medium is actually
going to be negative.
We'll call it a negative
refractive index material,
a negative index material.
So which of these two
do you think is which?
Why don't you turn
to your neighbor
quickly and chat about it
without peeking at your lecture
notes.
So let me walk through, as you
begin honing in on your answers
here.
Think about what would
happen to the reflectivity
of that front
surface of the water
and what would happen to the
angle that the light travels,
or the angle of refraction
of bending, shall
you say, as the light goes
from one medium to another.
So if we go to a refractive
index material of minus 1.3,
will we change the
reflectivity at all?
It depends, but the
answers here are shown,
for this particular system.
It would require
sitting down and walking
through the equations,
but in essence
right here, with the pool filled
with the negative refractive
index material, you're
really affecting
the angle at which light
is coming out of the pool.
Here you can see the corner
of the pool, which you
shouldn't even be able to see.
It's just that the
light traveled this way
and then came back because it
was a negative refractive index
material.
Light actually did something
like this, zoop, zoop.
AUDIENCE: What's in the pool?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Oh,
that's just a corner.
So what is in that pool?
That is a computer
generated graphic.
This is not a real pool.
There exists negative
refractive index materials
but not in that volume yet.
These are relatively small
things and very much a study
in fundamental science.
So in this case
right here, we have
less of an acute bending
of our angle of light.
So we don't get to see quite
as many features right here
toward the edge.
And the reflectivity
has changed as a result
of having drastically modified
our reflection condition.
AUDIENCE: Why does the
reflectivity seem to have gone
up and the index has gone down?
TONIO BUONASSISI: In
that particular case?
I think what they were getting
at-- this is coming off
of an SPI website.
I think what they were
getting at is mostly just
a change in the reflectivity.
So they were trying to emphasize
that you were modifying
the reflection off the
surface in addition
to the angle at which the
light was exiting the material.
I'm going to come back to
Snell's Law in a minute.
But for the time being,
I want to move on
to the next concept here,
which is Lambertian reflector.
You'll hear this topic or this
word thrown around quite a lot
in the solar cell community.
And it's used rather liberally
to mean a lot of things.
Although in optics, it has
a very specific meaning.
So I'm going to show you
that very specific meaning
and then describe for you
what it has very loosely come
to mean in the solar industry.
So a diffuse
Lambertian reflector
will follow a reflectance
that follows a cosine theta
dependence.
So if you have light
coming into a sample,
the surface normal, and
the outgoing light ray
form an angle theta.
And if the two are
perfectly aligned,
you get a lot of reflectance
off of that angle.
If the two are perpendicular
to one another,
you get zero reflectance
in that angle.
And so the reflectance parallel
to the surface here is zero.
In everywhere in between,
the magnitude of reflectance
is varying as consine theta.
That's the, I would
say, pedantic definition
of an Lambertian reflector.
Often in the solar
industry you'll
hear people, probably because
of a lack of optics background,
just call any randomly
reflecting surface
a Lambertian scatter.
It's a very loosely used term.
And it is wrong by the
book, but nevertheless, it's
one of these things that
live on in our industry.
So the difference between
a specular reflector,
the one that we've just
been analyzing right now,
and a Lambertian reflector,
is that typically the way
these are made is that you
do have a random texture
on your surface.
And that's probably where the
origin of this misunderstanding
comes about.
We don't get a
random reflectance
of the light coming off,
but the surface itself
can be rather texturized.
So, for example, if you suspect
that this little material
right here might behave
like a Lambertian scatter,
you might put it inside of
a tool and rotate the angle
and measure the amount
of reflected light
as a function of the angle
to determine whether or not
it follows this cosine
theta dependence.
And the reason it's important
is because the back skins
of our solar modules can quite
often be Lambertian scatters.
And we have a certain
amount of light
that comes off at
some angle here
that will get trapped by a
total internal reflection
inside of a modules.
So if, instead of having
macroscopic pyramids right
here, you had very, very
small pyramids-- still not
sub-wavelength, but
smaller features,
for example, the texturization
on the back skin right here.
An it managed to
scatter the light
at a particular
angle that got caught
by total internal reflection.
Macroscopically, we might be
able to describe the scattering
behavior of that surface
as Lambertian scatter.
But it's those waves, those
rays that are bouncing off
at those large angles
that are causing
the total internal
reflection event.
And so the notion of
a Lambertian scatter
is important on the backsides
of solar cell devices.
We would obviously wants to even
change the scattering profile.
We wouldn't want necessarily
specular reflectance.
We might want to maximize the
amount of light reflected off
at particular angles.
And there is, of
course, research
being done to figure out
how to make light do that.
I'll show you one example
at the very end of lecture,
a paper that was just
published in Science last week,
as an example.
And so these
scattering centers off
the backs of the
rear sides of cells
would operate more or less
in the following manner.
You'd have incoming light.
Let's ignore front
surface texturing for now.
Let's just focus
on the backside.
And if you have some random, as
we call it, a random reflector,
a randomly texturized reflector
on the back that reflects off
in, say, a Lambertian
fashion, you'll
have some fraction of
that light scattered off
at an angle that is large
enough relative to the surface
normal that it is trapped by
total internal reflection.
And you don't only have
to texture your back skin.
You can also texture
the bus bars.
The bus bars are these
little metal wires right here
that are collecting the charge
from each of the solar cells.
And they're connecting
essentially the front side
of one cell to the
backside of the next.
If you want to think about it
as the cathode to the anode,
cathode to the anode,
stringing all these
cells together in series.
And this metal right here
is just really shiny,
and it's reflecting light
right back out into space.
What if we instead were to
texture that metal so that when
laser light shined on it
a certain amount would
be reflected off at an
angle and then caught
by total internal reflection.
And that's exactly what
you're seeing right here.
The light bounced here
on a textured bus bar,
bounced off of the glass
more or less around here
halfway, and then
got a second chance
to enter the cell over here.
Obviously some of
it is reflecting off
so we can see it.
But a lot of it's going in.
And that little
innovation right there,
which was developed
in the building
right next door by
Professor Ely Sachs,
can gain module performances
somewhere on the order
of a few percent relative.
So that might not
sound like a whole lot,
but if you're a $100 billion
industry, 1% is a lot of money.
So it does add up.
So that goes back to the
total internal reflection.
So there is a limit to
all of this texturization.
There's a limit to how much
we can trap light simply
by modifying or
corrugating the surfaces
to enhance the optical path
length with these types
of bounces using Snell's
Law and of course
the general
reflectivity equations.
And a gentleman by the name
of Eli Yablonovitch, who's
now a professor in Berkeley
calculated these parameters
I think back in 1982 and
came up with an upper limit
to the optical path length.
He, after a long
series of calculations,
derived an expression
for the maximum increase
of the optical path length
due to surface texturing,
which was 4n squared.
And the Yablonovitch
limit to this day
is a pretty good litmus
test for the ability
of a material to trap light.
So if you have
silicon, for instance,
with a refractive
index of, let's say,
in the infrared some around
3.6, your Yablonovitch limit
is around 50, which means
that you can increase
the optical path
length by a factor 50,
relative to the thickness
of your material.
If you have an organic
material, which
has a refractive index typically
of around maximum 2, then
that would be squared, 16,
somewhere in that range.
You can increase probably
in the order of 20
the optical path length
inside of the material
through texturization.
So this is a useful
parameter for those
who are doing research
in photovoltaics,
the graduate
students especially.
And so I think the
graduate students
will have a question at some
point on the Yablonovitch
limit.
And so that's a useful
parameter to keep in your mind.
Let me touch upon a few other
forms of trapping light.
We've so far just
assumed that light
behaves like a
continuous wave, doesn't
interfere with anything,
doesn't interfere with itself.
Now we're going to discuss some
anti-reflection effects which
derives from the notion
that light is a wave
and can constructively and
destructively interfere.
What we have right here is
a layer of another material
with a refractive
index, say n1, which
is in between our
n0 which is at air
and our n2 is the
absorber material,
let's say the silicon.
So we have a grading
of refractive indices
going from air, our
anti-reflection coating,
to silicon.
And right over here we have
a certain thickness, d1.
And over here we have a
certain thickness, d2.
So what is happening
in these two images?
Let me show you with another,
a little bit more clear figure,
coming from our
beloved Wikipedia,
and then go back to that
other image right there.
So what's happening is we
have an incoming wave that
for some reason is
ignoring Snell's Law.
It's beyond me.
But anyway, the wave is
going in a straight line.
It should be bending toward
the surface norm, obviously.
But we have reflections
off of this interface
and this interface right here.
And because the
thickness of this layer
is in the order
of lambda over 4,
that means that the
wave that's going in
will be phase shifted
relative to the wave that's
reflected off the front surface,
first by lambda over 4 then
2 times lambda over
4, in other words,
lambda over 2, which means that
the two waves are out of phase
by lambda over 2, which means
that they will destructively
interfere.
The peak will be at a trough.
The trough will be at a peak.
So the two waves will are going
to be destructively interfering
when they come out.
If you add these two
together, due to the wave
nature of light, you get
suppressed reflectance.
And that's a really
interesting property.
You can begin varying the
thickness of this layer,
and of course changing the
nature of the reflected light.
You can constructively
interfere if you like
and enhance the amount
of reflected light
as a result of this
interference effect.
Obviously, in most solar cells,
we want to suppress reflection.
And so we go to great
lengths to make sure
that this thickness as well
as the refractive index
of the material is optimized
for a particular system.
And so without going
into the hairy math,
to calculate this right here,
it's definitely possible.
It's definitely something
that should be done.
And I believe the graduate
students have it assigned.
It's the very last
problem in the homework.
But for a very simple kind of
conceptual understanding that
is wavelength
independent, if we want
to minimize the reflectance at
a particular wavelength, let's
call it at a lambda
0, which is the photon
wavelength at the peak
of the solar spectrum,
we have to design the thickness
of our anti-reflection coating
to satisfy that
equation right there,
essentially lambda over 4.
That's the phase
shift we want upon one
pass of the
anti-reflection coating
so that two passes,
when it goes through
and then back,
it's phase shifted
relative to the surface
reflected light by lambda
over 2, divided by n, n
being the refractive index
of the material.
Obviously the frequency of
light is staying the same
as it goes from one
material to another.
But the wavelength
would be changing.
So that's why the n
parameter appears right here
in this equation.
The t is the thickness of the
optimal anti-reflection coating
thickness.
So just to give us a
sense, kind of an estimate,
and to give us some confidence
in these engineering
methods, what I'd
like you to do is
to calculate the thickness of an
ideal anti-reflective coating.
This anti-reflective coating
right here on these cells--
I apologize, they also have
the metal on the front,
so it's a little difficult to
distinguish between the two.
But in my right hand, this one,
I have a piece of bare silicon.
And you can see it's
rather reflective.
In my left hand
over here, I have
a piece of silicon with
an anti-reflective coating
as well some contact
metalization on the front.
So that's why you
see those grid lines.
But it looks very blue.
It looks very blue
because the cell
is absorbing very well at the
peak of the solar spectrum
which is in the yellow.
So calculate for me what
is the optimal thickness
of an anti-reflection
coating of silicon nitride?
And we'll give it a
refractive index of, say, 2.1.
Let me see if those
numbers make sense,
so refractive index of silicon
nitride somewhere around 550.
Let's call it 2, just
make our lives simple.
And the peak of the solar
spectrum we'll again call 550.
So why don't we run
the numbers quickly.
What should that thickness be?
AUDIENCE: Tonio,
I'm sorry, could you
repeat the constant again?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Sure.
So the n, the refractive
index, is going to be around 2
for silicon nitride.
So we're going from air, which
is around refractive index one,
to silicon nitride, the silicon.
And the peak of the solar
spectrum, our lambda 0,
which is the photon
wavelength at the peak
of the solar spectrum in vacuum
or in air, is 550 nanometers.
So what thicknesses are
folks coming up with?
Order of magnitude.
AUDIENCE: 70 nanometers.
TONIO BUONASSISI: 70 nanometers.
That's almost spot on
to the actual thickness,
to somewhere on the
order between 70 to 80
nanometer typically.
You're telling me that
something that is 1/1,000,
the thickness of my hair,
is deposited on the surface
of this wafer and is
absorbing all this light?
That's pretty cool.
And it's not
absorbing the light.
The anti-reflective
coating is not
absorbing the light,
which is really important.
We want the solar
cell underneath it
to be absorbing the light.
The anti-reflection coding
is enabling the light
to be absorbed because it's
suppressing the reflectance.
The reflected modes at
that particular wavelength
are suppressed because of
the destructive interference.
That's cool.
I really get a kick out of
anti-reflective coatings.
So they're 70 nanometers thick.
And you gain quite a lot in
terms of cell performance.
I'll show you some slides to
drive that point home in a bit.
This is really really briefly--
I'll post these slides online
so you can have access to them.
If you use the matrix
transfer method,
as described beautifully in
[? Gonchen's ?] textbook,
you can calculate the
amount of light reflected
across a broad spectral
range for a given thickness
of anti-reflection coding.
So what we did right
now was to calculate
a suppression of the light
at a particular wavelength.
But you can also calculate
with the tools that
are available to
you the reflectance
of your particular device
over a broader wavelength.
Range and that's pretty
cool because now you
can begin, say, multiplying
this function right
here against your solar
spectrum and begin
to calculate the total amount
of light entering your sample
and the total energy
entering your sample.
Equations, brilliant.
The important thing
to note here is
that it really, really matters.
This is silicon under
glass right here,
for example, typical solar
cell material in blue.
It's better than
the bare silicon.
Why is it better than the bare
silicon, silicon under glass?
Glass has a refractive
index of 1.5 or so.
AUDIENCE: The index matching.
You go from pairs 1 to 2.3
and then to [INAUDIBLE].
The difference is small
between the classes.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Exactly.
So if we recall
that equation that
described the amount
of reflectance,
there was that-- what was it--
n1 minus n2 quantity squared,
right?
So the bigger the delta
between the ends, the bigger
the difference in
refractive indices
between material one
and material two,
the more the reflectance is
going to be off that interface.
And so you can begin
reducing reflectance off
of a stack of light
going both ways
by grading the refractive
index of the material.
And that, of course, changes the
reflectance in both directions.
And so you get a reduction
in the total amount
of reflected light when you
put the silicon under glass
because glass has a refractive
index somewhere between air
and silicon.
And then you get a
further reduction
of the reflectance when you
have an anti-reflection coating
with a refractive index
somewhere around--
for this particular
system, silicon again
has a higher refractive index.
This used in anti-reflective
coating of a refractive index
of 2.3 of some
thickness, probably
somewhere around--
let's see, it'd
be greater or smaller,
probably around 65,
75 nanometer
somewhere that range.
So what this is
saying is that you
can minimize the
reflection of light
off of the front
surface of your sample
by using an intelligent
combination of the very
first equation that we're
exposed to in the class
today, which was the
reflected light as a function
of refractive index, so
essentially refractive index
matching and secondly, by
engineering by engineering
an anti-reflective
coating, which oftentimes
in the lingo of
solar cell science
we call it an ARC, an
anti-reflective coating.
And those two things combined
give us very low reflection
off of the front surface.
Probably 5% of our R&D
cells that we make at MIT
use these sorts of
technologies, which are pretty
standard in the industry.
And you can see what
the hit is, right?
Let's see, if I'm just
using a bare material,
if I'm getting 30%
reflection, I'm
getting a 30% drop in the
current output of my device.
That's pretty significant.
So these are simple ways to
improve performance of devices.
If you want to become
fancy and actually do
what's called a ray tracing
to calculate the path of light
through a medium, there
is software available
that will take all of
what we've discussed today
and calculate it
for you so you don't
have to walk through
the expressions
that we just walked through.
It is easy.
In other words, you
plug something in.
You get some ray traces.
You can calculate reflectance
and so forth, transmittance.
But it's as smart as
what you put into it.
It's really important to
understand the fundamentals
behind any simulation software
because you will get out
of it what you put into it.
You will not be able to
pick up on obvious things
that you might of--
for example, double
clicked on this
little material here
and find the real component of
the refractive index completely
wrong.
And you might not notice it.
You might not pick
up on it if you
don't have some good
intuition which is
grounded in the fundamentals.
And so it's important
that you understand
what we've presented today.
It's important you understand
the reading and, of course,
do the p-set as well to really
drive those fundamentals home.
So to kind of put a big umbrella
over the entire lecture,
light management ensures
that the absorbtance is high.
The absorbtance would
be, essentially,
the amount of light
getting absorbed inside
of the material, normalized by
the amount of light going in,
so 1 minus r.
So we want to ensure that
light enters the absorber.
We want to minimize reflection.
We want to ensure good light
trapping inside of the absorber
as well, the absorber
being the material,
our photovoltaic material, the
ones absorbing the sunlight
and ultimately going to
be generating the charge.
So we call it the absorber.
So we want to ensure good
light trapping inside it.
We want to ensure the
maximum amount of light
gets trapped inside.
We want to maximize the
optical path length within it.
And we want to
minimize reflectance
off the front surface.
There are fancier ways of
light management as well
that don't involve light
trapping necessarily
but light manipulation or even
semiconductor manipulation.
You can, for instance,
change the wave length
of the incoming light.
One very simple
example of this is
when you shine, say for
example, red light on a phosphor
and then it glows
green in the dark.
That's a wavelength
change-- maybe not red.
You'd probably have to shine
blue to have it glow green.
That's an example of a
spectral down converter where
it's taking a
higher energy light
and converting it into
lower energy light.
Likewise, there
are folks out there
trying to do spectral up
converters where they take
two lower energy photons
then somehow convert that
into a higher energy photon.
And so since our
absorption coefficient
is dependent on
wavelength, if we're
able to shift the wavelength
of the light around
by engineering materials
near the surface,
we can enhance
absorption as well.
That is a form-- a valid
form-- of light management.
It has additional
benefits as well.
If we can eliminate the longer
wavelength stuff out here,
which is heat, performance
of most solar cell
suffers when they get hot.
And we'll learn why
that is about five
or 10 lectures from now.
And so if we manage to
do spectral up converting
or reflect that long wavelength
light away from our device,
we can improve
performance there as well.
That's another form
of light management
that doesn't necessarily
involve light trapping.
So again, I wanted
to really emphasize
that light management
is necessary devices.
This is no light
trapping, the blue curve,
and with light trapping, light
trapping being essentially just
an engineered coating
on the backside,
on the backside of your
device, of lights coming in
through here.
I've engineered a
coating on the back
to reflect the light back so
that it gets a second bounce
through the material.
I've engineered
the front surface,
texturized it so that we have
not only the benefit of two
bounces, double the
chance of light going in,
but also the Snell's
Law working in our favor
and increasing the
optical pathway.
And so all told, the one
reason why this boost is so big
right here is because I'm
increasing the optical path
length, the effective
optical path
length, relative to the
thickness of my material.
And as a result, I'm getting
a much larger current output.
I'm generating many
more free carriers
instead of my material.
I'm absorbing much
more light inside
of my material, just a very
simple calculation versus cell
thickness.
And obviously the thicker
and thicker and thicker
you go in your device, the
less important this becomes.
Because the less important
light trapping-- I mean,
you have the entire thickness.
I can absorb the majority
of the light in one pass.
But if you have
a thinner device,
it really begins to matter.
Once the thickness
of your device
starts approaching the
optical absorption, or 1
over the optical absorption
coefficient, which
is the extension
length, then it really
begins to matter in
the absorption length.
Light trapping can still matter
for thick devices, though.
Because if you manage to make
the light essentially refract
or bend, if you will, so that
it travels near the surface,
the distance that
those excited carriers
have to travel to be
collected is shorter.
And so you can get an additional
benefit from thicker devices
by engineering light
trapping as well.
OK, any questions about this?
This is kind of important.
This is why we spent all
this time in lecture today
talking about light management
is because of this plot right
here.
That's why.
I just wanted to show
you a cross section
of very high efficiency device.
This is one of the
highest efficiency
silicon-based devices
are out there.
And we have these
so-called backside mirror,
which is really just a layer
of dielectric material,
typically, that
reflects the light off
of that interface
using the equation
that we saw at the very
beginning of class,
the r equal to [INAUDIBLE]
n minus 1 quantity squared
divided by open parentheses
n plus 1 quantity squared.
So that's benefiting here from
the change of refractive index
going through your silicon
to that dielectric material
in the back.
They definitely take
good advantage of it.
Where you have
your metal, you're
going to be absorbing the light.
Or you have a higher probability
of absorbing the light
than you would if you had
a dielectric semiconductor
interface.
So the device design can
get pretty complicated
for these super high
efficiency devices.
And they're worried quite a bit
about trapping, other things
as well.
AUDIENCE: Coefficient,
is that one there?
TONIO BUONASSISI:
This one right here?
In the lab, 24.2%, in commercial
production, 22% and change.
22.4%, I think.
Just to throw some
last things out there
since we're five
minutes to closure.
Snell's Law assumes that there's
no phase shift of the light
as it transfers from
one medium to another.
If you introduce a
phase shift-- this
is just a paper published
in Science last week
by our friends over at
Harvard, Federico Capasso.
If you introduce a
phase shift of the light
as it goes through
one medium or another,
now you can start
doing some fun things.
If you introduce a constant
phase shift gradient
throughout the surface of a
material, let's say right here,
then you can cause
each node, each point
within your material, to
lag by an increasing amount,
so that your wave
front now bends.
You can think of these as kind
of a Huygen wavefront forming
as a result of these
small nodes here.
And if you can tailor
the phase independently
at each one of these points, you
can cause an increasing delay
as you go across.
And that will cause
the light, essentially,
if you trace through the
points of maximum intensity,
say the pink, you'll see
that the light is bent.
And that's pretty cool.
Because now we
can, in principle,
if this is hot off the press--
and then of course there's
a whole flurry of researchers
out there trying to figure out
how to use this
to our advantage,
but with anomalous refraction,
in principle, now you
can tailor the angle at
which light bends inside
of the material.
Perhaps you can even exceed
the Yablonovitch limit
inside of the material
as a result of this.
And so it's really exciting.
There's stuff
coming up every day.
This is the point.
There's stuff coming out every
day on light trapping and light
management.
Mostly it's for
photonic devices.
But they can be transferred
over into solar cells as well.
So it's going to
keep your eyes open.
And another example
of the photon up/down
converters, there's
recent reports in SPIE,
a lot of interest in
the optics community.
There was a TR35 award
given to a person who
studying this topic.
So it is, as well, a
very exciting and up
and coming field.
Again, the opportunities
there of manipulating
light are large, are vast.
So the laws, if you
will, that constrain us,
that we've discussed
today in class,
don't let that
constrain your thinking.
That's my final message.
Thanks.